the maesters don't believe in prophecy
with good reason
the children of the forest supposedly
could see into the future yet was
surprised by the first man who nearly
ended their race and the long night
which nearly ended dissolve some
maesters posited the children's magical
sight was invented long after they
vanished from Westeros by singers hoping
to thrill peasant girls not that most
masters have much experience in what
does or doesn't do that when Aegon the
conquerer came to the Iron Islands the
priest King low-dose claimed his divine
father the iron bonds drowned God had
shown in Krakens pulling Aegon's ships
into the deep nor Krakens ever arrived
and even if they had they wouldn't have
stopped Aegon and his dragons without
wings of their own confused lourdes
filled his pockets with stones and
walked into the sea to take counsel with
his father
thousands followed him but apparently
the drowned God didn't appreciate a
crowd their corpses washed upon the Iron
Islands for years according to legend
House Targaryen survived the doom of
Valyria thanks to Gainey's the dreamer
who foresaw the calamity and convinced
her father to flee their homeland it
could be true the Targaryen 's were
always a bit more but as maester Yentl
points out in the east the Targaryen is
one of a thousand minor noble families
and in Westeros they became kings
politics not prophecy could have drawn
them to our shores
politics can also explain the prophecies
of daemon Blackfyre ii a Targaryen
bastard rumored to possess the family
gift while posing as a hedge Knight he
told a future Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard that he dreamt of a dragon
hatch in a white walls Castle and took
it as a sign that he'd win the Iron
Throne
perhaps if he'd slept a bit longer he'd
had dreamt of the Kings hand putting
down his rebellion a day later before it
even began most maesters dismissal
Targaryen claims of prophecy as mystic
nonsense a relic of their Eastern
ancestry to be fair across the Narrow
Sea there isn't a market without a wall
up from Qarth telling fortunes or a
shadow binder from a shy reading faith
seat blood up so I hear from the
maesters but when I was a boy I
overheard the cook whispering to her
maid about a woods which camping outside
horn Hill who was called Maggie the Frog
now I realize it was probably a
corruption of the Eastern word for
wizards Maggie
one day my father rode out hunting
though no game was in season and
whatever power she had likely didn't
save her even the wisest maesters
however have no answer for the red
priests who prophesy about the return of
the long night for thousands of years
they've kept watch for the return of the
prince who was promised who will be born
amid salt and smoke to drive off the
darkness once again
Prince of what realm promised by whom
and to whom the prophecy doesn't say but
at the very least he confirmed that not
even Essos escaped a long night I
imagine the Cataclysm must have confused
the East
unlike Westeros they wouldn't have known
of a night king nor the White Walkers or
the war waged by the first men and the
children of the forest they would have
just seen a terrible winter descend and
linger far too long until spring
magically returned to the world yet
somehow maybe from passing merchants
maybe in their fires the red priest saw
the truth now the truth is here again
for anyone to see but the most is
refused they debate and question and
doubt not to choose the wisest course
but because they're too used to doing
nothing else
most prophecies might be lies but not
all of them the long night is coming if
we don't believe that
well we won't need any prophecy to tell
us our future hey everybody so the Game
of Thrones DVDs are dropping so they
have all these bonus features that
they're releasing to talk about
prophecies that have a lot of Easter
eggs for the series in the cast is
continued to do a bunch of interviews
that we need to break down talking about
some of the conflicts that are going to
be happening during season 8 and how the
characters are going to be moving around
so if you are finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there is a new round of the
giveaway for the DVDs I'll explain at
the end of the video but starting with a
really cool stuff first you may have
heard the easter egg for what maester
ebro's and all the other masters were
talking about when Samwell was still at
the Citadel so Samwell is narrating this
prophecy trailer he has that bit about
the ancient Ironborn king low dose that
prophesied the destruction of Aegon the
conquerer when he was coming to conquer
the Seven Kingdoms with his ships in the
way they use that as well as the other
prophecies of this trailer in the way
the TV show used it during season seven
is a way for them to say that this is
all ridiculous
and so that theme continues with all the
different prophecies that Samwell talks
about during this feature but the funny
thing about that is that in the same
breath during season seven they also
named Drop Jenny of old stones I'll play
the clip in a second it's just a brief
moment but the Jenny of old stones
prophecy did end up coming true we will
write to mr. vulcan at Winterfell for
clarification I promise you we will get
to the truth of it one way or another
arts mr. Mayall Tolly it brings to mind
the work of taking those stones the
charlatans who claimed descent from the
children of the forest they forget the
dose you promised that the drowned God
would rise up and destroy Aegon the
conquerer if you never heard the Jenny
of old stones prophecy it's actually
part of this larger historical event and
it's sort of a precursor to r+ l equals
J so what happened is as Jenny of old
stones was a person who is in love with
Prince Duncan Targaryen who was the
oldest son of King Aegon v Targaryen the
egg from the Duncan egg series the tales
of Duncan a side note you may also
remember that Aegon v was the younger
brother of maester aemon that's why he
was calling for egg mother's calling you
as he was dying so Aegon the fifth son
Duncan wants to marry this girl Jenny of
old stones in this very r plus l equals
j situation Jenny had a woods witch
friend that came to court with her who
prophesied that the prince who was
promised would come from the line of
Aerys ii who was the mad king in
princess raela the person who was the
mother of Rhaegar Targaryen so the cool
thing is is that Aegon v allowed the
marriage to continue because his son had
been betrothed to one of the Baratheon
's at that point so he broke that
engagement to marry Jenny of old stones
so that he could engineer a scenario
whereby the line of Aerys ii would
eventually give birth to Jon Snow
so that prophecy did come true even if
you consider the interpretation of the
prophecy is genderless so they also gave
birth to Daenerys Targaryen who's the
other part of that prophecy the prince
or princess who was promised it's just
that Jon Snow and Daenerys came from
different parts of that line of
succession
Daenerys came from Aris ii himself Jon
Snow came from heiresses son Rhaegar but
his Samwell also narrates that bit about
the children of the forest having Future
Sight it clarifies their powers a little
bit but the maesters also doubt that
because they're like if they had Future
Sight then how come they didn't see the
long night coming it's just that they're
taking too
dural of an interpretation with that
ability they don't fully understand how
greensight works there's also that funny
bit where he implies the final fate of
Maggy the Frog now he himself thinks
it's a bit of an old wives tale because
he heard talk of a Maggy the Frog when
he was a child but his father rode out
into the woods and killed this person
but we ourselves know that Maggie the
Frog was real because of Circe's
memories of her we even saw her on the
TV show so you can kind of see at
various points here there are some
things that wound up coming true there
are some of these things that are false
it's all meant to reinforce the idea
that prophecy as Melisandre says is a
tricky thing just don't treat it in too
literal of a way but I do like the way
that the maesters faces change to whites
at the end sort of implying some things
that are going to be happening during
season eight the actors themselves have
been doing a lot of different interviews
I think I talked about some of them in
my last Game of Thrones video they've
continued to do that
Sophie Turner talked about the different
kind of battle that she's going to have
during season eight it's going to be
much more emotional so people are
wondering what that means in what that
probably means is that she's going to be
battling for Jon Snow's soul like he'll
find out that he's a Targaryen and start
to identify with that he has this
relationship with Daenerys Targaryen
so it sounds like they are implied that
there's going to be a battle for Jon
Snow's identity within Jon Snow but also
externally - like Sansa wants him to
remember that he's a stark but Jon will
be all conflicted because of the things
that have been happening with Daenerys
but let me know in the comments if you
want me to do more videos for these
featurettes like this there are at least
three or four more they're actually
pretty cool there'll be a whole bunch
more Star Wars dropping really soon and
there is a new round of the DVD giveaway
all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
my last video Mark Brian please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post new Game of Thrones
click here for my non-spoilery Star Wars
the last Jedi review and click here to
learn all about the season 8 release
date thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight